first one came in from arturo who says
what details would you say are most
relevant in a story I tend to talk too
much I'm Arturo would you tell Arturo I
think I'll Tara that's a great question
and with stories is it's part of it is
kind of listening and asking the right
questions but first of all you've got to
go where your audiences and then
secondly you gotta look what is your
audience needs and relay that to your
story I think they are the key things
and then connect your story with the
needs of your customers and if you do
that I think particularly through kind
of social media and make it authentic
and super clear I'm really crisp then
then it's very very powerful and
compelling and I think to Evans point as
well you know if you look at these big
companies you want to get away from that
don't follow the big guys be true to
yourself follow your story because make
it personal because that's what people
want to hear and anybody can get these
big brand agencies coming and you know
rewrite their website you look at any
other big corporates in you know kind of
NYC companies or big companies and they
look the same but your story is unique
to you and be proud of it and make it
part of your DNA so everything you do
around your product and your services
connect it with your audience and really
apply it to them and I think they'll
follow you I think the most important
part of the story the first store you
have to tell us your foundation story
why did you start this thing why is it
so important to you what makes you come
alive about your business I and you
don't have to be great on camera and you
don't have to be you know great at
speaking you can just start by having on
your website on the about page don't
just give me your resume give me some
emotion like let me feel something when
I read your bio or when I do hear you
speak I wanted I want to hear something
I want to feel like man that guy really
really cares about what he's doing and
so the foundation store is really
important and just before we started
Steve and I were talking about stage
summit that's coming up and Richard
Branson and and scene was telling about
how Richard started Virgin Airlines
maybe you want to recap that story
quickly Steven yeah and this says
something
so important if if you were angry about
a gap in the market then that means
you've got a product you got an
opportunity to solve that Branson was
stuck down in the Caribbean and he got
bumped off a couple of planes and he got
stranded and because of that that gave
him the incentive and the anger and the
passion to say I'm gonna I'm gonna have
a low-cost airline that is front and
center focused around customers and you
know the rest is history is built Virgin
Atlantic probably one of the best brands
highest customer service all these sort
of things and he stayed true to to that
that foundation story that drove his
passion in the first place didn't know
they were awakening a sleeping giant
there that the Menace he created and by
providing him terrible service it's so
true it's so true and a no say you know
it's great to have when you're you know
when you're a young scrappy and hungry
it's great to have a gorilla to go after
so in the early days he kind of went
after british air and the kind of
transatlantic airlines because they were
kind of you know not doing a great job
in terms of customer service they were
expensive they were late they didn't
care about customers they worried more
about the unions for their employees and
they did about their customers to be
honest with you so he saw a gap in the
market he got angry he got stranded in
the caribbean and he said actually i'm
going to change that i'm gonna give a
service that customers really value and
build an airline around customers and do
it cheaply for them so they can travel
around the world and do what they want
to do and pursue their dreams what i
love about it is a lot of companies will
say you know we value our customers and
customer service is number one and this
is what we stand for but when you hear
the story of branson being you know
upset at an airline and being kicked off
the plane and you've been so frustrated
with it that kind of brings it home a
little bit more makes you feel like he
actually does care about customer
service and isn't just paying lip
service to it I think that's important
less at least that I take out of it for
entrepreneurs is you can have your
mission statement and you can have your
values you can have what you're all
about it that's fine but to make it
believable you have to tell me the
background story behind it so that I get
emotionally attached to it